so I have a pretty fun job which is to
figure out what makes people happy it's
so fun it might almost seem a little
frivolous especially at a time where
we're being confronted with some pretty
depressing headlines but it turns out
that studying happiness might provide a
key to solving some of the toughest
problems were facing it's taken me
almost a decade to figure this out
pretty early on in my career I published
a paper in science with my collaborators
entitled spending money on others
promotes happiness I was very confident
in this conclusion except for one thing
it didn't seem to apply to me
I hardly ever gave money to charity and
when I did I didn't feel that warm glow
I was expecting so I started to wonder
if maybe there was something wrong with
my research or something wrong with me
my own kind of lackluster emotional
response to giving was especially
puzzling because my follow-up studies
revealed that even toddlers exhibited
joy from giving to others in one
experiment of my colleagues Kylie Hamlin
Lera Ackman and I brought kids just
under the age of two into the lab now as
you might imagine we had to work with a
resource that toddlers really care about
so we use the kind of toddler equivalent
of gold namely goldfish crackers we gave
kids this windfall of goldfish for
themselves and a chance to give some of
their goldfish away to a puppet named
monkey
[Music]
but you know I don't see any more treats
will you give one to monkey now he
trained research assistants to watch
these videos and code toddlers emotional
reactions and of course we didn't tell
them our hypotheses the data revealed
that toddlers were pretty happy when
they got this pile of goldfish for
themselves but they were actually even
happier when they got to give some of
their goldfish away and this warm glow
of giving persists into adulthood when
we analyze surveys from more than two
hundred thousand adults across the globe
we saw that nearly a third of the
world's population reported giving at
least some money to charity in the past
months remarkably in every major region
of the world people who gave money to
charity were happier than those who did
not even after taking into account their
own personal financial situation and
this correlation wasn't trivial it
looked like giving to charity made about
the same difference for happiness as
having twice as much income now as a
researcher if you're lucky enough to
stumble on an effect that replicates
around the world in children and adults
alike you start to wonder could this be
part of human nature we know that
pleasure reinforces adopted behaviors
like eating and sex that help perpetuate
our species and it looked to me like
giving might be one of those behaviors I
was really excited about these ideas and
I wrote about them in the New York Times
one of the people who read this article
was my accountant
at yeah at tax time I found myself
seated across from him watching as he
slowly tapped his pen on the charitable
giving line of my tax return with this
look of like poorly concealed
disapproval
despite building my career by showing
how great giving can feel I actually
wasn't doing very much of it so I
resolved to give more around that time
devastating stories about the Syrian
refugee crisis were everywhere I really
wanted to help so I pulled out my credit
card
I knew my donations would probably make
a difference for someone somewhere but
going to the website of an effective
charity and entering my visa number
still just didn't feel like enough
that's what I learned about the group of
five the Canadian government allows any
five Canadians to privately sponsor a
family of refugees you have to raise
enough money to support the family for
their first year in Canada and then they
literally get on a plane to your city
one of the things that I think is so
cool about this program is that no one
is allowed to do it alone and instead of
a group of five we ended up partnering
with a community organization and
forming a group of 25 after almost two
years of paperwork and waiting we
learned that our family would be
arriving in Vancouver in less than six
weeks they had four sons and a daughter
so we raced to find them a place to live
we were very lucky to find them a house
but it needed quite a bit of work so my
friends came out on evenings and
weekends and painted and cleaned and
assembled furniture when the big day
came we filled their fridge with milk
and fresh fruit and headed to the
airport to meet our family it was a
little overwhelming for everyone
especially the
four year old his mother was reunited
with her sister who had come to Canada
earlier through the same program they
hadn't seen each other in 15 years
when you hear that more than 5.6 million
refugees have fled Syria you're faced
with this tragedy that the human brain
hasn't really evolved to comprehend it's
so abstract before if any of us have
been asked to donate 15 hours a month to
help out with the refugee crisis we
probably would have said no but as soon
as we took our family to their new home
in Vancouver we all had the same
realization we were just gonna do
whatever it took to help them be happy
this experience made me think a little
more deeply about my research back in my
lab we'd seen the benefits of giving
spike when people felt a real sense of
connection with those they were helping
and could easily envision the difference
they were making in those individuals
lives for example in one experiment we
gave participants an opportunity to
donate a bit of money to either UNICEF
or spread the net we chose these
charities intentionally because they
were partners and shared the same
critically important goal of promoting
children's health but I think UNICEF is
just such a big broad charity that it
can be a little hard to envision how
your own small donation will make a
difference in contrast spread the net
offers donors a concrete promise for
every ten dollars donated they provide
one bed net to protect a child from
malaria we saw that the more money
people gave to spread the net the
happier they reported feeling afterward
in contrast this emotional return on
investment was completely eliminated
when people gave money to UNICEF so this
suggests that just giving money to a
worthwhile charity isn't always enough
you need to be able to envision how
exactly your dollars are going to make
difference of course the group of five
program takes this idea to a whole new
level when we first took on this project
we would talk about when the refugees
would arrive now we just refer to them
as our family recently we took the kids
ice-skating and later that day my
six-year-old Oliver asked me Mommy who's
the oldest kid in our family I assumed
he was talking about his plethora of
cousins and he was talking about them
but also about our Syrian family since
our family arrived so many people and
organizations have offered to help
providing everything from free dental
fillings to summer camps it's made me
see the goodness that exists in our
community thanks to one donation the
kids got to go to bike camp and every
day of the week some member of our group
tried to be there to cheer for them I
happen to be there the day the training
wheels were supposed to come off and let
me tell you the four-year-old did not
think this was a good idea so I went
over and talked to him about the
long-term benefits of riding without
training wheels then I remembered that
he was four in barely spoke English so I
reverted to two words he definitely knew
ice cream you try without training
wheels I'll buy you ice cream here's
what happened next
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is the kind of helping that
human beings evolved to enjoy but for 40
years Canada was the only country in the
world that allowed private citizens to
sponsor refugees now Canada pretty great
now Australia and the UK are starting up
similar programs just imagine how
different the refugee crisis could look
if more countries made this possible
creating these kinds of meaningful
connections between individuals provides
an opportunity to deal with challenges
that feel overwhelming one of those
challenges lies just blocks from where
I'm standing right now in the downtown
east side of Vancouver by some measures
it's the poorest urban postalcode in
Canada we actually debated whether to
bring over a family of refugees because
there's so many people right here
already struggling my friend Evan told
me that when he was a kid and his
parents drove through this neighborhood
he would duck down in the backseat but
Evans parents never would have guessed
that when he grew up he would open up
the doors of a local restaurant and
invite this community inside to enjoy
three-course dinners the program that
Evan helped build is called plenty of
plates and the goal is not just to
provide free meals but to create moments
of connection between people who
otherwise might never make eye contact
each night a local business sponsors the
dinner and sends a team of volunteers
who help make and serve the meal
afterward the leftovers get distributed
to people who are out on the street and
importantly there's enough money left to
provide a thousand free lunches for this
community in the days that follow but
the benefits of this
program extend beyond food for the
volunteers it provides an opportunity to
engage with people to sit down and hear
their stories after this experience one
volunteer changed his commute so that
instead of avoiding this neighborhood he
walks through it smiling or making eye
contact as he passes familiar faces all
of us are capable of finding joy and
giving but we shouldn't expect this to
happen automatically spending money
helping others doesn't necessarily
promote happiness instead it matters how
we do it and if we want people to give
more we need to subvert the way we think
about charitable giving we need to
create opportunities to give that enable
us to appreciate our shared humanity if
any of you work for a charity don't
reward your donors with pens or
calendars reward them with the
opportunity to see the specific impact
that their generosity is having and to
connect with the individuals and
communities they're helping we're used
to thinking about giving as something we
should do and it is but in thinking
about it this way we're missing out on
one of the best parts of being human
that we have evolved to find joy in
helping others let's stop thinking about
giving as just this moral obligation and
start thinking of it as a source of
pleasure thank you
[Applause]